Насправді це не так.
ЄС справді має безвізові режими з Україною,
Грузією та Молдовою, громадяни яких можуть
без візи перетинати кордони ЄС
за наявності біометричних паспортів.
Але така можливість дається лише на 90 днів
і без права працевлаштування.
Приміром, безвіз з Україною, який вступив у силу
11 червня цього року, не спричинив
масового напливу українців в ЄС.
Торгові відносини між ЄС і країнами-партнерами
взаємовигідні, підкреслюють у Брюсселі.
Експорт ЄС до України зріс на 12 відсотків, а експорт
України до країн ЄС на 3,7 відсотків.
ЄС став для України головним торгівельним партнером.
Експорт українських товарів до ЄС становив
минулого року понад третину в загальному обсязі
і сягнув майже десяти мільярдів доларів.
ЄС ретельно контролює, на що і скільки
витрачається грошей, виділених для країн-партнерів.
До того ж, один з головних пріоритетів ЄС у
країнах-партнерах - це боротьба з корупцією.
ЄС фінансово підтримує також інші значущі
реформи - у сфері правосуддя, виборчого права,
держуправління, поліпшення бізнес-клімату тощо.
Мета "Східного партнерства" - позитивні зміни
в житті громадян ЄС та країн-партнерів.
Для цього Євросоюз заохочує
демократичні принципи та правління.
Але ЄС на нав’язує жодних конкретних дій чи
програм своїм країнам-партнерам.
Стабільні, безпечні і процвітаючі країни-сусіди
в інтересах громадян ЄС,  адже це важливо
для стабільності, безпеки і розвитку самого Євросоюзу.
Крім того, "Східне партнерство" створює додаткові
можливості для бізнесу з обох боків -
шляхом доступу до нових ринків та споживачів.
Також зростають можливості для туризму
та освітнього обміну.